[Music]
[Music]
guillermo ariaga is perhaps best known
to date for his remarkable collaboration
on three films with fellow mexican
director inaritu
amores peros 21 grams and babel
preferring to describe himself as a
hunter who works as a writer ariyaga
claims to write from personal
circumstances injecting his stories with
events that he has experienced or been
involved with
his films are characterized by
multi-stranded narratives interweaving
several characters who are connected
directly and indirectly by a single
dramatic event
through his multi-layered approach he
explores themes of grief guilt love
chance and alienation
with the exacting quality of his writing
it is no surprise that arriaga has
played an instrumental role in putting
mexican cinema on the world stage
every time someone asks me a question
instead of answering with a concept i
answer with a story
if i don't tell stories i think they
will grab me from
the throat and
squeeze me and kill me so i
i i feel
that i have to tell them in order not to
be killed by them
you know
i think that screenplaying comes from
several places
sometimes screenwriting
comes from an idea of someone else
so you develop the idea that someone
else has
sometimes you write historical
interpretations on something
and sometimes the screenwriting comes
from personal places originals
and
i think that you have to measure the
screenwriting from from where it comes
from the stories i've been telling have
been
very personal stories
for example amoris perez i i don't know
you have cinemas perez but amores perros
involves dogfighting
well guess what i have a dog
whose name was coffee i was eight years
old he used to run away all the time and
there were dogfights where i grew up
and then they have this champion dog and
say hey why don't you
make this dog kill guillermo's dog just
for fun
but my dog killed the other dog so i use
that story to tell
the story of amoris perez
the agreement with alejandro gonzalez
pero says that first if it's going to be
the great of him by what's going to be
shared
and
that meant that i was
through all the process
i was with him in custody i was with him
and in many steps i'm not saying with
this that i was directing not at all
we were thinking that we were we were
going to work as as a team like the coin
brothers
he and inuritu started out at the same
you know started collaborating together
and they made you know several films um
amorous perils and then 21 grams which
really kind of took the world by the
scruff of the neck and kind of announced
a new movement in mexican filmmaking and
in international cinema
um
[Applause]
is
um
[Music]
when i wrote amores perros
it comes from two places first i have a
car accident
uh
i was sleeping on the back seat with no
no seatbelt
many years ago and we
we fell on a cliff
so i woke up in the middle of the
accident
and i become so obsessed with the
accident that i wanted to write a
trilogy of films based on accidents and
i was obsessed with what happened before
the accident what happened during the
accident and what happened after the
accident so that's the structure of
amores perez
i remember the day i was going to
release the moles perros the day before
i have a
chat with a friend of mine a
screenwriter who made a lot of
concessions to his screenplay to make it
commercial a lot of concessions
and i said man why did you make such so
many concessions to to your to your
screenplay it was beautiful now it i
cannot even recognize it and say because
my friend i'm going to be in hollywood
your cd-rd movie about dogs is going to
be seen by
two people
mine is gonna bring me to hollywood
it's not my friend that's not the way it
works
why do we think that we have to put
rules on storytelling
just because a greek philosopher stayed
2000 years ago it has
who says that in page 30 page 60 page 90
we have to follow always the same
i think that every story has a different
way to be told
it's one of them
and we have to realize that in in real
life in in our daily life we use
extremely sophisticated
storytelling
we never go linear
we never structure with the first act
second acting reaction
we always use this
back and forth
of storytelling
so why
we have to always with this kind of
structure
i have read all these manuals of
screenwriting
they say things that i will never follow
and i have learned that the first rule
of screenwriting or any art is having
no rules
everyone has to find its own
way of doing things
for example
every screen writing teacher says
research
research research research is the clue
to everything and i say
i'm so lazy to research
and first i'm talking about myself and
the things that happen to me so why i
have the need to research at all
so i do not do any kind of research
ever
i wrote a film that takes place in
morocco and
bible and a story in japan i have never
been to morocco and i have never been to
japan i make no research about how
people live in japan i make no research
of people how living in morocco
i've never been with with
i have been with uh
goat
house goat keepers
in the mountains of the desert of mexico
and i'm sure they behave the same of the
moroccan
goat
you know and i have a teenage girl in
mexico city i'm sure that a teenage girl
in japan will behave exactly the same
so why i need to research
i don't do any kind of research ever i
don't write any kind of uh
character development you know this
backstory thing that means
never i don't write any outlines
or treatment ever
i don't have a preconceived structure
ever i just sit down and write
[Music]
one of my favorite films that he was
responsible for is 21 grams 21 grams is
a film about kind of unimaginable
horrors things that we just we never
want to face you know the death of a
child or the death of a loved one or a
or a an illness that's going to kill us
um now that they could be uh subjects
that really kind of turn you off a film
that make it make it una you make you
unable to watch it but that's not what's
happened here's an incredibly kind of
skillful way of dealing with really raw
emotions head-on
you mind if i joined actually i was just
leaving
maybe just until you finish no maybe
next time
did you know that eating alone can cause
kidney damage and that's bad
i have a mild infection in my heart
nothing serious but i was trying to be
part of the
i wanted to
have a tryout in the boxing um
for the olympics in the boxing team for
the olympics in the mexican team
and i was training so that mild
infection in the heart became
a mess
it went from the pericardium which is
the membrane that
it's around the heart to the muscle and
the doctor told me the infection goes
inside
you need a heart transplant it never it
was never close
that i will have a transplant but just
thinking about it
make me right about 21 grams
all those thoughts
that what will happen if i die
and
once i was with a friend we were 12
years old
and he was 16 we have a high powered
rifle
uh 306 caliber rifle and it's said in in
the bullet spots it say it can have a
reach of five miles
and the guy was like no way
five miles nah
should be
500 yards
no it says five miles why don't we shoot
the cars
far away we were in the desert so we was
watching cars and say let's shoot them
and see if it really hits
so far away they were like
a kilometer away
and he was like i said no don't shoot
them maybe what about if it's true
that's not true
and this is the original bubble
still
[Music]
i was once in one of these
i was writing a screenplay and the
producer because i'm come from from the
novels insisted that i have to go to
one of these gurus of
screenwriting
seminars
and this was a woman and she was saying
you must know everything about your
character
everything you have to write up
the whole backstory of your character
you must know even how much change it
has in this pocket what kind of
underwear is wearing and i say [ __ ] this
is so boring
if i know everything about my characters
how i'm going to be surprised by them
so i have no idea
at all of where my characters are coming
from who their parents i have no idea
i'm not interested in it i have no idea
what the end is ever
i discover it i always say if you have
an idea of how it's going to end what's
the fun of writing it
i know many writers say if you don't
have the end don't write it and i say
again how boring is that
if i know the end what's the purpose of
writing the story
i like to discover at the end so i have
no idea at the end
the way i work in hollywood is i pitch
my stories to producers
and
to serve our producers and they and many
of them is like okay and what happened
next and i
have no idea
what's the end i have no idea and you
want me to pay this amount of money for
something you have no idea how it's
gonna end yeah it's gonna end good don't
worry
so i like i love to discover the end
i hate when i know everything
so that's why i don't write an outline
why write a treatment
and
i have no preconception i have no
preconceived ideas i have just a very
vague idea of where the story is heading
and what structure it needs
so the way i write the stories
is i sit down
and begin writing
now i've been teaching seminars
and many people is asking me if there's
any technique
and i think that
the only technique
for writing has to come not from the
technique itself but from questions
about important things
there's something that causes a lot of
anxiety
in riders
is the notion that we have only
one gallon of ink
and that sooner or later we run
out of that gallon
and
if
you pay the bills writing like it's my
case
you send
the kids to school with your writing
you are terrified
that you
will have nothing else to say
forever
we never know
when this
finishes
we hope it never ends
the way i begin writing is is very
simple i have a like a
story that happened to me when i was
young or that happened to me these kind
of stories stay in my head for years and
years and years
so then i i have an idea of how they
begin
i don't have a
preconceived structure
i have some idea of how it's going to be
destructive and i have some idea of how
the story is going to be
where it's moving toward
but i have no no really
unorganized logical
steps to go
there i just began writing and if you
look at something like babel which has
you know four different stories each of
which has three different time frames so
you're really kind of messing with an
audience's head trying to kind of unpick
who's where and what you know
and i think what it what it forces you
to do by telling a story in that kind of
rather unconventional way
is is is forces you as an audience
member to really get what's important in
the story to really kind of understand a
kind of you know
what a character is trying to do or what
they're going through sometimes what
drives me to to to have a the structure
is a concept
a basic concept for example in
the brain plane the concept was the four
elements
i wanted to have a story of water i want
to have a story of earth i want to have
a story of of wind and the story of fire
and i have these elements that i wanted
to go through all these stories but
that's the only thing that really gave
me some kind of structure even though i
knew it was an area film and i knew it
was going to be a kind of jumble of
narrative to a certain extent i spent
the first half an hour of the film
really trying to kind of impose my own
sort of narrative norm on it without
before i suddenly remembered or realized
that actually those things aren't
important and that you just need to kind
of focus on the moment
and that's how you'll get the best out
of the film and you know
when i subsequently saw the film i
realized that watching the first 10
minutes wouldn't have helped me at all
in trying to kind of piece things
together in the way that i was like i
was watching a normal film
what did your mom wear to bed
a slip
can you put it on
i'm wearing my father's shirt
you promise not to touch me
i promise
every time i write a scene
or a story
and it's not working i think
how will shakespeare solve this it
happens to me in a more especial
amount of person there was a story it
wasn't working
and i say how can it work and i say
shakespeare
and shakespeare
way of doing things is the closest the
characters are the greatest the conflict
think of
hamlet
who killed
hamdet's father
who is marrying
hamlet's mother
macbeth
mark whether he he wants
the throne
in order to kill the throne
he has to kill the king
but
the king is his best friend
and the one who's pushing him to kill
his best friend is his wife
so when you put things
so close
conflict becomes
much
larger bigger
so that's something i use
that's a trick that i give to you
things like shakespeare
guillermo screenplays are fantastic to
read they're incredibly kind of poetic
not flowery but poetic they have they
have the language is very very simple uh
he sums up a lot of kind of individual
moments that would perhaps normally be
in the hands of a director they would be
the things that you would think of as
being this is what the director has
brought to a film as opposed to a
screenwriter but they're not the you
know the individual poetic um
visual
moments in this
of the film are often down to guillermo
script
sometimes in in in the rehearsal and
sometimes because
as you can see english is not my
mother tongue
they tell me you know something
in english it will sound better like
this but
so they make me some comments about how
the dialogue sounds
in spanish now in spanish i'm absolutely
sure how it's going to sound
no no doubt about it in interest of
course i have some doubts
not very often
i sometimes i invent expressions
[Music]
i have like a rule to write one line
dialogue so
it's not difficult to build in english
and i don't want to portray them like
the slang kind of guy that knows the
streetwise
kind of
talking you know it's very
straightforward
narrative moving dialogue and sometimes
i i'm just hear some expression and i
try to put it like have a hint
of slang but i'm not obsessed with
trying to look
like a particular thing
that's makes it that makes it difficult
but
but i have a
translator who works very close to me
and
he tells me yeah it will sound a notable
sound sometimes i bury
storm and say let it that way say no one
speaks like that english i don't give a
damn leave it that way
i've been very actively involved in most
of the films i have i have written
i have even producer credit in some of
them
i'm even an actor in one of them
and i'm very close to the films except
for babel
where i was have trouble with the
director i've been very closely involved
with the other ones even even in the
editing room because the way i write
the screenplays
taking a thing out
creates a snowball effect
so i have to be there and be sure that
the structure will not be uh falling
down
i i it has to be very meticulously
cut
well i think when you hand over your
work is because you are trusting the
director especially something so
personal and it has to do basically with
a matter of taste
if they have a good taste
and they have a
similar approach of what you think of
the film i think it's the right director
for example
the first time i met tommy jones
i
we began talking about literature and i
asked him which is your favorite
living american author writer and he
said come on mccarthy and say wow
it's the same not me which is your
favorite filmmaker
and among many names he pick up kurosawa
and he says turn turn back to you there
were the the um
the
sketches that kurosawa
[Music]
have
grown for
i think it was run
so i said well he likes kurosawa
and then he liked the trailers
and trailer parks and these uh
kind of places
and he liked the desert and he liked
hunting so i say i i i can easily make a
film with this guy because we have so
much many things in common and if we
have a skeleton here right now
we will kind of
feel a little bit of comfortable
but nothing serious
but what about if i have a
guy who has just three days dead
a rotten corpse
be feeling comfortable
what happens
with a rotten flesh that
creates such anxiety
on us
what happens with the smell why why
don't we we are not shocked to have a
skeleton here and we are so shocked if
we see a caliber here
so i decided
that i would like to to have a corpse
being
a protagonist of a film
smells like something dead around here i
killed a deer a couple days ago starting
to turn
yeah
well you better throw it away it's
rotten i want to keep the hide you got
any salt i could use to cure it
no son i barely got enough salt to put
on the dinner table you got any alcohol
or anything like that
i got a jug of antifreeze
would that work
suck on this hose
yeah man's won't eat him anymore after
this
you're crazy
i think what gamma is concerned to do is
to find the connections between
apparently random acts i mean he
famously doesn't
start with a kind of beginning middle
and end nor does he end with the
beginning middle and end in any story he
starts with a series of images or of
small random incidents things largely
that have happened to him um and he
finds something interesting about them
you know a particular illness that he
has or you know seeing a building
burning when he was a young boy um you
know those things he's obviously kind of
stored up and and finds a story to go
with them but you know what's
interesting about them ultimately is how
he then finds connections between those
individual stories and the individual
characters that he's dreamt up
and how they all interrelate
you cannot write linear and then cut and
paste
because the way the
a non-linear kind of structure that i
use the way it works this is another
trick this is because of the dramatic
questions you need dramatic questions
and that dramatic questions you must
feel them
you have to feel them i don't have this
like this kind of writer who had the
wall full of papers with where's going
everything i have it in my head
i know where i'm going more or less
in 21 grams
i knew that the audience because it was
so chaotic needed a
a handle bar for they had to grab
for me the handlebar was going to be the
light
21 grams is written
in light
what do i mean
for example the the first part of 21
grams
it it happens during the day
this means a character have some light
in in their in their lives they are
living more moral as well and the
audience understand that this is a part
because it's like it's this is
subconscious i i'm sure that you have
not noticed it
if you have seen 21 grams the second
part is all during the night
and the third part is
a don or dusk
and that's on purpose and that comes
from the screenplay
it hurts a lot when they say in 21 grams
such great editing
not my friend
the structure comes from the from from
the screenplay i mean there is a sort of
fairly conventional narrative arc going
on um but it is kind of chopped and
changed now i always had imagined that
that would happen at the edit um that
that would be much more of a
collaboration between editor and
screenwriter
you know coming back to kind of
make the story more interesting but
apparently that's not how it happens and
you know the screenplays that we look at
uh you know the published screenplays
that we look at which are extraordinary
close to the to the edit the the edited
film that we all know that they're so
close and you know that's that's the way
he imagined it and many people think
that i really write linear and then cut
and paste
no
i just sit and write because you have to
feel things
the process of discovering
uh
art
is the same as discovering the person
you love
it needs surprises
and the more profound is the
storytelling the more profound
is the the the the person you love
i think what guillermo allows us to do
is to face some of the most awful things
that we couldn't imagine the the the
kind of absolute life and death issues
but he does it with a kind of likeness
of touch that
i don't know where he gets it from that
that allows us to kind of you know spend
time with these characters going through
such awful things
without wanting to kind of run for the
door
if there's too much
planning
and there's too much
preparing
what you're going to write about you
will not be surprised by it
that's what i i don't like to write in
the tree structure kind of things on
page 30 i don't like to have no
backstory about the characters i don't
like to have an outline and
i want to be as free
as possible to
have these things coming naturally
you cannot decide if it's going to be a
success or not
there's no way of designing that
there's no progress in art
your last work is not going to be better
than your first one
so the best the best thing is to be
authentic and and honest with your own
work
[Music]
[Music]
you